peu c'est pour ça que moi j'espère mais
c'est une c'est un souhait pas plus que
ça c'est pas une directive enverrait les
britanniques que dans leur
positionnement
le gouvernement britannique a essayé de
trouver un compromis entre les grands
partis britanniques parce que en fait la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
européenne c'est pas la sortie du parti
conservateur douanes européennes
c'est là qu'ont pris avec les
libéraux-démocrates par exemple aulas
c'est pas à moi de donner des directives
avec qui doit gouverner mais il est
clair quand même que une majorité des
gens dans ces élections n'ont pas voté
pour une ligne du revendeur à exceet et
ça c'est quand même une toute autre
signal d'une tout autre message que les
mais teresa mais pour l'instant on n'a
pas entendu semble-t-il